[Applause]
an invisible powerful force is lifting
professional basketball to new heights
[Applause]
transforming how this
multibillion-dollar sport is played
[Music]
in elite sport a difference between
success and failure is often the finest
of margins the Houston Rockets are one
of the top teams in NBA basketball they
boast some of the sport's biggest stars
including the NBA's most valuable player
in 2018
you know offensively we're trying to do
in defensively what we're trying to do
so the focus is trying to be on the same
page every possession for every game in
the past decade the Rockets have risen
from mid table mediocrity to serious NBA
championship contenders but it's not
just big names that have fueled this
dramatic ascent it's big data the data
that we go over is definitely important
you know I think it gives us a you know
a little bit of an edge you know to keep
a balance of data and instinct is a big
thing
the Rockets recent success owes much to
their pioneering decision to start
crunching data about every aspect of
their game and this is the man
responsible analytics has really
permeated everything our edges allowed
us to win the most games 65 last year
computer scientist Daryl Morey is the
sports for most data and statistics guru
among NBA bosses you can break winning
down into two things one is how many
points do you get per possession and
then how do you get extra possessions 10
years ago
Daryl set out to find that winning
formula the Rockets were one of four NBA
teams to install a pioneering video
tracking system which mined raw data
from games what they discovered changed
the way teams tried to win the data
revealed which shots provided the best
bang for buck two-point dunks and
three-pointers shot from outside the
three-point line rather than long-range
two-point shots from inside it
[Music]
[Applause]
it's pretty dramatic how powerful the
three-point shot is you only have to
make a third of your three-point shots
to be worth a half a or two even within
that there's an extra miss be my rebound
offensively in the 1990s long two-point
shots from just inside the three-point
line were common but Darryl's analysis
showed that statistically these shots
provided the worst return a number of
attempted three-point shots has
increased every year for the past decade
in the 2017-18 season the Rockets made
more three-pointers than any other team
in NBA history and this was a major
reason they won more games than any of
their rivals every percentage matters in
sports and extracting those percentages
is what's really become much easier with
data we're in a in a pretty big
transformational stage in sport
[Music]
professor receive Mahesh Hren co-founded
second spectrum the analytics companies
gathers and codes a vast range of
increasingly granular data for all 30
NBA teams it feels like Dooley chess
pieces cameras now track and record 3d
spatial data for every player and ball
movement at 25 frames per second machine
learning technology uses this huge
volume of data to produce interactive
visualizations allowing teams to analyze
the my new shy of their performances and
achieve marginal gains on court
at first we taught the machine about
twenty terms right now it knows over 500
basketball terms so the machine is
essentially the integrated knowledge of
all the elite basketball coaches there
is a particular focus on all important
data around player movement and the
probability of making a shot what we can
do with them with the machine is to say
look at all the shots like this one and
tell me the chance that this shot really
could go in either for this player or
for an average player and you bring in
all the things that a person can see not
just where they're standing but how
they're moving what type of a shot
they're kind of take where are the
defenders and and what we can do is we
can put a number two what previously was
a feeling or something qualitative data
analysis has even changed the type of
players that successful teams like the
Rockets have players today are on
average leaner and more agile having
skilled players even if they're little
smaller is more important than having
bigger guys who are are less skilled
when it comes to recruiting new players
from the college draft each season
poring over data on player performance
has given the Rockets a winning edge
we've been able to eke out about a 5
percentage and that actually turns out
to be a massive advantage basketball has
constantly changed but it's about to
enter a brave new world where data could
be courtside in the hands of coaches
helping to swing a game as it happens
the data is always getting faster and
faster the data used to take hours we've
got it down to minutes and very soon
it'll be down to seconds basically going
to become functionally real-time very
very soon I don't think we've scratched
the surface of what's possible with data
[Music]